bananas and Africa have a significant
relationship when it comes to Banana
production the cultivation process in
Africa is fascinating as it integrates
traditional farming techniques with
meticulous care and a deep connection to
the land quality banana production
begins with planting a banana seedling
known as a sucker rather than from seeds
these suckers Sprout from the base of an
existing banana plant
we're about to delve into the African
jungle to explore how these large
clusters of bananas are cultivated and
harvested stick around it's going to be
exciting Farmers regularly remove weeds
that compete with banana plants for
nutrients and water but they also ensure
that the plants receive ample water
through irrigation
systems a new airspring technology has
been particularly helpful in this regard
as bananas grow Farmers monitor the
closely until they reach the ideal stage
for wrapping to protect them from
pesticides and ensure proper
growth once bananas reach their optimal
size experts carefully Harvest them
using sharp knives or machetes each
Bunch can weigh up to 40 kg so
harvesting is usually a team effort to
avoid damage during
Transportation special methods are
employed to transport these delicate
fruits without bruising or
contamination banana chips are beloved
worldwide for their crunchy texture and
sweet flavor if you're interested in how
your favorite snacks are made you're in
the right
place bananas are typically harvested
while still green so they're firm enough
for processing at the factory they
undergo thorough cleaning before being
sliced and fried into crispy
chips beyond their Delicious Fruit
almost every part of the banana plant is
useful banana leaves serve as natural
plates or wrappers in many cultures due
to their sturdiness and subtle flavor
addition strawberries also play a
crucial role in various culinary
Delights from short cakes to Tarts and
cheesecakes thanks to their natural
sweetness which often requires minimal
added sugar while traditionally
handpicked due to their delicate nature
new robotic technology has emerged for
harvesting ripe strawberries
efficiently in modern factories
strawberries undergo multiple cleaning
stages before being processed into
various products like canned or frozen
strawberries or strawberry jam all while
maintaining strict hygiene standards
through minimal human
contact pineapples follow an equally
intriguing Journey from Farm to Table
Farmers cover pineapple seed beds with
special sheets that retain soil moisture
and control temperature by reducing
evaporation a critical step especially
in dry regions
[Music]
once pineapples mature they're tested
for ripeness using refractometers before
being harvested carefully due to their
spiky leaves Modern Machinery AIDS
Farmers by transporting heavy pineapples
directly from Fields without manual
labor
strain in processing units pineapples go
through rigorous washing before being
sorted by weight for balanced packaging
some pineapples are further processed
into peeled chunks or fresh juice using
Advanced Machinery ensuring no part goes
wasted from peels used elsewhere down
even pulp separation during juicing
processes finally packaged fresh juice
bottles get sealed tightly preserving
tropical goodness ready anytime you
crave it canned juices undergo similar
meticulous processes ensuring freshness
and flavor intact upon opening each
can whether it's bananas turned into
chips strawberries transformed across
different states or pineapples Juiced
and canned the seamless integration
between traditional practices and modern
Technologies ensures top-notch quality
and sustainability throughout these
agricultural Marvels
[Music]